good morning Hank it's Tuesday last
night I dreamt that there were two
ligers walking through my backyard a
liger being the offspring of a male lion
and a female tiger this struck me as
pretty unusual and conceivably
impossible so I began to investigate the
situation within my dream I considered
for instance that there is often
wildlife in my backyard deer coyotes
foxes one time I saw a beaver it did
seem unlikely that there would be two
langurs given their rarity but I
reassured myself that they were probably
brother and sister also laggers are not
native to Indianapolis so they had
probably escaped captivity and if you
were an escaped liger in central Indiana
my backyard is one of the places you
might seek out because it is wooded and
contains lots of potential food mostly
in the form of four million Chipmunks
all in all it seemed perfectly possible
to me that sibling ligers had escaped
their cages to dine in my backyard
the problem of course is that my
investigation of the liger situation
began with the conclusion there are
liars in my backyard and then I worked
my way back to the story of how they
came to be there rather than pausing to
consider that the loggers I thought I
saw might have been for instance deer or
that I might have been say dreaming my
friend Amy cross Rosenthal once said
correctly that nothing is less
interesting than other people's dreams
and I apologize for introducing you to
my subconscious but I mention all of
this because it seems to me that the
liger delusion is at the heart of a lot
of contemporary discourse especially
around politics you start with what you
already know to be incontrovertibly true
that Republicans are crooks who only
want to line the pockets of their
wealthy donors or that Democrats are
crooks who want the government to
control every aspect of human life and
then you look for the how and why I mean
these days it can be difficult to even
know when you believe in a conspiracy
theory in part because conspiracy
theories are sometimes true and in part
because no matter the subject the closer
you look the more you see put another
way the more you consider laggers might
be roaming indianapolis the more
explanations you'll find for why take
for instance the fall in conspiracy
theory which may of course prove to be
true Republican donor Elliot Brody paid
a woman over a million dollars not to
discuss their alleged affair that's
known but the conspiracy theory holds
that the actual affair was between that
woman and Donald Trump and then Brody
stepped in to cover up that affair and
make
payment now if you look for explanations
of why broidy might have done this you
will find them broidy has profited
tremendously from the Trump presidency
he also has a history of covering up
affairs for his friends and no stop
because none of that means he covered up
an affair for Trump of course the same
happens on the right where conspiracy
theories from Benghazi to pizza gate are
presumed true by many but my worry is
that many of us are falling into the
trap of believing that we however we
define that we are the ones alive to the
real reality while those who disagree
with us are mere sheeple a term that
literally dehumanizes others you see
this all the time with people saying
wake up or keep dreaming as if only
those we disagree with can fall prey to
the liger delusion what I have found
while looking for laggers is this I am
far more likely to believe in allegation
to be true or to be important if it
confirms my pre-existing worldview and
if it would challenge my worldview I am
likely to believe it to be false or else
irrelevant sometimes on TV news or
political radio or podcasts you'll hear
the phrase we don't yet know all the
facts but and then after the but comes
some speculation or a statement of
implication like we don't yet know all
the facts but someone saw to ligers in
the backyard we know that Hank I have to
stop beginning with the conclusion I
have to stop speculating ahead of the
story and instead wait for the facts to
come out and I have to stop saying but
after we don't yet know all the facts
but I don't know how this is the part of
the video where I turn it around and
find reasons to be hopeful and make a
call to action but I don't know how I do
think being aware of our conspiratorial
instincts can be helpful but I don't
know how to escape the laggard illusion
Hank I'll see you on Friday